Imagine que entre em dois locais de trabalho.
O primeiro está desarrumado.
As ferramentas estão largadas no chão.
O lixo está espalhado por todo lado.
O equipamento está sujo.
As pessoas dizem,
está bom assim.
Agora imagine o segundo local de trabalho.
As ferramentas estão limpas.
Tudo está no seu lugar.
O chão está varrido.
O trabalho está bem feito.
As pessoas têm orgulho no que fazem.
Em qual dos dois locais confiaria mais?
A maioria das pessoas escolhe o segundo.
Por quê?
Porque a atenção ao detalhe constrói confiança.
Atenção ao detalhe significa importar-se com as pequenas coisas.
E aqui está o segredo.
As pequenas coisas tornam-se as grandes coisas.
A forma como estaciona o seu carro diz algo sobre si às outras pessoas.
Estaciona o direito?
Deixa o espaço suficiente para a pessoa seguinte?
Pensou nos outros?
A forma como deixa uma sala diz algo sobre si.
Apagou as luzes?
Arrumou tudo?
Empurrou a cadeira.
Para o lugar?
A forma como trata as suas ferramentas diz algo sobre si.
Estão limpas?
Estão guardadas no lugar certo?
Cuida delas como se fossem suas?
Um profissional não atira ferramentas para o chão.
Um profissional respeita-as.
A forma como termina um trabalho diz algo sobre si.
Limpou a área antes de sair?
Removeu o lixo?
Verificou seu trabalho uma última vez?
Ou apressou-se para a tarefa seguinte?
Atenção ao detalhe não é sobre ser perfeito.
É sobre importar-se.
Imagine dois pintores.
Ambos terminam de pintar a parede.
Um deixa a tinta no chão, pincéis sujos e fita ainda coladas de anelas.
O outro limpa os pincéis, remove a fita com cuidado, limpa o chão e deixa a sala impecável.
Ambos pintaram a parede, mas só um trabalhou com excelência.
Aqui está outro exemplo.
Recebe um e-mail.
Um tem erros ortográficos, informação em falta e nenhuma saudação.
O outro é claro, educado e fácil de entender.
Qual das duas pessoas parece mais profissional?
A segunda pessoa.
Os detalhes importam.
Aqui está outro exemplo.
Repara numa pequena fuga de água.
Pensa, são só umas gotas.
Uma semana depois é uma reparação grande.
Atenção ao detalhe significa notar pequenos problemas antes de se tornarem grandes problemas.
É assim que os profissionais pensam.
Aqui está um hábito que o vai tornar excelente.
Antes de terminar qualquer tarefa, pare durante um minuto e pergunte a si próprio.
O que é que me escapou?
Isto está limpo?
Isto é seguro?
Sentiria orgulho se o meu chefe, o meu cliente ou a minha família visse isto agora mesmo?
Esse minuto pode fazer toda a diferença.
Lembre-se disso.
As pessoas podem não reparar em todos os detalhes que acerta, mas quase sempre reparam
nos detalhes que erra.
A sua reputação constrói-se uma pequena ação de cada vez.
Uma ferramenta limpa.
Uma linha direita.
Um espaço de trabalho organizado.
Um e-mail escrito com cuidado.
Um carro bem estacionado.
Uma verificação extra, antes de dizer, terminei.
A excelência não é uma grande decisão.
São milhares de pequenas decisões tomadas todos os dias.
Por isso, hoje, preste atenção aos detalhes.
Tenha orgulho no seu trabalho.
Deixe cada lugar melhor do que o encontrou.
Trate cada ferramenta com respeito.
Termine cada tarefa com cuidado.
Porque as pessoas que se tornam excecionais não são as pessoas que, ocasionalmente,
fazem grandes coisas.
São as pessoas que fazem consistentemente bem as pequenas coisas.
É isso que é a atenção ao detalhe.
E é isso que é a excelência.